c'est un jour de grand oral aujourd'hui
je le disais puisque l'association des
maires de france l'assemblée des
départements de france région de france
recevait les candidats à la
présidentielle pour un grand oral un
grand oral consacré aux collectivités
locales à la décentralisation à
l'articulation des relations entre
l'état et les élus locaux et les
collectivités
source de beaucoup de malentendus de
quiproquos voir de tensions depuis le
dernier quinquennat on revient sur sur
ses relations un peu tendues comme nous
le résume nicolas fleury
c'est un absent qui sous gros emmanuel
macron n'a pas fait le déplacement face
aux élus locaux aujourd'hui les
candidats qui ont décidé de venir ont eu
raison vous en déduirez que les autres
ont eu tort réactions amères du
représentant des maires de france à
l'image des tensions qui ont longtemps
opposé le président et les édiles en
2010 est déjà avant même son élection
emmanuel macron est accueilli par les
huées
alors
je fais partie des décideurs politiques
qui refusent de faire siffler ses
opposants au meeting je viens pas devant
les maires de france pour me faire
siffler la raison la suppression
annoncée dans son programme de la taxe
d'habitation principale ressource des
communes une des premières mesures qu'il
a appliquée traduit trop difficile on a
l'impression que notre fonction n'est
pas
pas reconnu à sa hauteur par les
services de l'état on pourra pas
continuer comme ça crédit annulé
autonomie limitée certains maires se
sentent dépossédés de leur pouvoir mais
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
impossible pour le président de se
passer de ses élus les plus populaires
les plus proches des français alors il
leur réserve une place centrale dans son
grand débat national
puisse l approche de la présidentielle
il tente de reconquérir les édiles
je veux ici vous dire non seulement la
reconnaissance de la nation mais vous
dire l'engagement de la nation toute
entière
à vos côtés des communes aux régions ce
matin les collectivités demandent à
peser davantage la république pour
qu'elle soit solide elle doit avoir des
fondations solides et les fondations
solides c'est reconnaître les
territoires et c'est faire en sorte qu'à
travers la décentralisation le pouvoir
local chacun puisse se sentir pro connu
les collectivités appelle à des réformes
plus profondes
comment mieux défendre les libertés
locales faut-il aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation qu'elles sont le bon
niveau des des relations état
collectivités ce qu'elles sont forcément
conflictuelle puisqu'elles peuvent être
conçus comme un partenariat on en parle
ce soir avec martial foucault vous êtes
professeur des universités à sciences po
directeur du cevipof et auteur notamment
de mer au bord de la crise de nerfs aux
éditions de l'aube j'accueille aussi à
vos côtés françoise gatel sénatrice
centriste d'ille et vilaine et
présidente de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales du sénat
mathieu darnaud bonjour sénateurs et
l'air de l'ardèche et co-rapporteur
d'ailleurs on en parlera tout à l'heure
du fameux projet doit qu'ils avaient non
absolument délirant le projet de loi et
décentralisation la déconcentration et
la différenciation et mais qu est l
autre des trois et puis j'accueille
aussi par écran interposé éric kerrouche
sénateur socialiste des landes et
coauteur d'un livre à paraître la
décentralisation pour contre ou avec
l'état à paraître le 22 mars le disait
aux éditions de la documentation
française pour commencer ce débat marcel
foucault est ce qui a encore des
factures net dans le paysage politique
français sur la question des
collectivités locales ah oui j'ai eu
même qu'elles n'ont jamais été aussi
importantes
pour moi le point de référence et c'est
tout le débat des années 80 au moment où
d'ailleurs année 2022 on va célébrer les
40 ans des lois de décentralisation et à
l'époque c'est vrai que le débat oppose
et les jacobins aux girondins 1 et ce
clivage finalement n'est pas totalement
épuisé aujourd'hui mais il s'est
transformé
en raison principalement du
chamboulement ou du paysage politique
c'est à dire que les positions on a
connu le communisme municipal on a connu
le socialisme municipal
et puis on voyait que les grandes
collectivités locales étaient
massivement gérées par la droite
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a changé dans
ce jeu des transformations du paysage
politique c'est que une forme de
cohabitation verticale qui se met en
place c'est à dire que au plan national
on a dès l'émergence de formations de
mouvements politiques nouvelles quand je
dis nouvelles qui ne sont pas rattachés
aux partis de gouvernement de la vème
république et puis au plan local après
les élections municipales et
départementales et régionales de 2021 on
voit que les familles politiques
traditionnelles sont installés au plan
local alors on a le plan local c'est
neny girondins ni jacobins sont les
partis traditionnels et puis au plan
national des formes nouvelles qui
apparaissent et ça ça transforme
totalement la relation et notamment pour
les élus locaux et les maires cette
difficulté à comprendre si aujourd'hui
ils doivent
prendre quelle position vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs nationaux ou des pouvoirs
locaux auxquels ils sont plus familiers
que l'émergence de nouvelles formations
et quand j'ai dit nouvelle formation le
parti du président la république qui a
toutes les peines du monde à pouvoir
s'installer au plan local ou bien c'est
la même chose pour marine le pen dsk
dans le cas où la france a soumises
d'une salle aussi certaine façon et éric
kerrouche on vient de parler enfin
marcel foucault bien d'employer le terme
de jacobins et de girondins ont
l'impression que plus récupère sonne se
réclament du jacobinisme aujourd'hui
plus personne ne revendique le fait
d'être un centralisateur
s'il ya encore des centralisateur en
france par exemple emmanuel macron je
n'ai pas vu pendant ce quinquennat qu'il
avait été décentralisateur
il a été il a été malgré lui mais voilà
dans les séries le discours dans le
discours plus personne n'ose dire je
suis un centralisateur mais c'est pas le
cepac discours qui compte ce sont les
actes et depuis les actes en fait on
voit bien que nous n'avons pas été dans
une période de deux décentralisations ou
de reconnaissance forte des libertés des
libertés locales d'ailleurs les
différents textes qui ont été des textes
territoriaux pendant ce quinquennat sont
des lois qui sont inégalement important
mais qui d'une certaine façon ne porte
pas les mêmes ambitions que celles que
l'on a connues en 1982 en 1992 et dans
les années dans les années 2000
françoise gatel parmi les candidats
présents aujourd'hui d'entendre cette
grande journée de grand oral il ya ceux
qui ont été élus et les autres ceux qui
ceux qui n'ont pas forcément été sa
chaire on peut regarder d'ailleurs on a
on a une infographie on résume un peu ce
truc ceux qui ont été élus locaux et
ceux qui n'ont pas été ça change quoi
voilà on va si on regarde voilà ceux qui
n'ont pas eu une expérience d'élu local
et yannick jadot et macron eric zemmour
et tous les autres ont une expérience
d'élu local quel que soit les mandats ça
change quoi au fond d'avoir été élu
local ça change elle à la connaissance
du sujet
je pense que quand on a été élu local on
est tenté par une obligation de réussir
terre pour les habitants que vous voyez
pas ce qu'ils sont présents archil
d'apporter nos gars il faut que ça
marche donc vous pouvez avoir une
doctrine mais en même temps vous savez
que la france elle est forte de sa
diversité vous savez j'ai une obligation
de résultat donc vous parler d'un sujet
que vous connaissez quand vous n'avez
pas et élu local c'est un peu comme un
ingénieur peut-être qu'il n'a jamais
fait de mécanique alors qu'on sait bien
que l'action publique elle se fabrique
c'est du sur mesure très souvent donc
un candidat qui a été élu local quand il
parle aux élus locaux je vous parle d'un
bep il je connais bien voilà quand vous
n'avez pas été élues locales parfois moi
j'entendais dans la salle tout à l'heure
des mères qui disaient oui alors c'est
très bien le propos mal en moi je peux
dire que ça ne marche pas
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu le fond
d'hypocrisie aussi parfois de la part de
certains partis qui ont les candidats
viennent faire des grandes déclarations
enflammées d'amour aux élus locaux alors
que eux mêmes à la tête de leur parti se
targue parfois d'enjamber le des
scrutins locaux comme si ça ne les
intéressait pas comme si au fond il n'ya
que la présidentielle qui les
intéressaient qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mathieu darnaud moi je pense que
c'est un sujet qui mérite qu'on s'arrête
dessus et je reprendre les propos qui
ont été de ceux de david lisnard
aujourd'hui on ne parle pas d'un sujet
technique on parle d'un sujet éminemment
politique parce qu'en réalité et c'est
regrettable que certains candidats ou
partis en jambes ce sujet parce que il
est au coeur de toutes les difficultés
tous les maux de notre société les élus
locaux depuis maintenant cinq ans ont dû
faire face à cette crise des gilet jaune
ils ont été en première ligne parce
qu'ils connaissent plus que quiconque
notamment les sujets de la ruralité ils
ont été en première ligne sur la crise
sanitaire quand il a fallu traiter des
protocoles scolaire de l'acheminement
des masques quand il a fallu mettre en
place des centres de vaccination est là
aujourd'hui encore sur la scène et
l'actualité internationale ce sont eux
qui au côté de l'état assure l'accueil
de réfugiés les réfugiés donc on parle
d'un sujet qui touche le quotidien de
nos concitoyens et je ne conçois pas
qu'un projet présidentiel puisse faire
abstraction de ce sujet qui est pour moi
le sujet d'avenir parce que ça a été dit
oui aujourd'hui il existe une approche
jacobine c'est à mon sens celle du
président de la république et puis des
volontés plus girondine en tout cas qui
base une partie de leurs projets de
leurs visions politiques sur l'action
des dans les territoires pour une raison
c'est tout qui est toute simple c'est
qu'on voit que là où les sujets ont du
mal à accoucher au niveau national il y
a une intelligence une agilité
collective qui dépassent très souvent
les partis politiques sur les
territoires et on arrive à faire là où
on a du mal à avancer parfois au niveau
national et ça je pense que c'est
essentiel parce que c'est aussi une
raison d'espérer pour nos concitoyens
oui juste la crise sanitaire a montré
aussi un paradoxe c'est à dire que les
maires disent toujours non mais laissez
nous faire et puis on sait bien faire
tout seul et ils n'ont eu de cesse de
demander de l'aide auprès de l'état d'y
centraliser et centralisateur donc il ya
toujours ce paradoxe aussi est-ce que
c'est pas une litanie finalement qui ont
bien de jean raquin attention à ce que
moi je les maires ne demande pas agir
seuls les maires ce qu'ils veulent c'est
que face à une décentralisation assumé
il y une déconcentration assumer est ce
qu'on a défendu dans la loi de 3d c'est
justement que face à cet esprit
décentralisateur il y est la volonté
d'inscrire l'état au plus proche des
territoires
territoriales c'est le préfet ce sont
celles et ceux qui agissent en proximité
est trop souvent on se heurte un état
centralisé qui a du mal à se réformer
qui a du mal à faire confiance tout
simplement aux territoires alors venir
dans le détail est ce que dira tout
petits mots je partage pas tout à fait
votre analyse je me rappelle comme
chacun de nous de ce dimanche de juin
2020 18 heures le président de la
république vient intelligent il explique
que tous les enfants de france doivent
retourner à l'école très bonne idée sauf
que lui il termine son propos il rentre
à l'elysée qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière ses larmes et des élus locaux
les maires les conseillers
départementaux et régionaux qui met en
place toute une organisation très comblé
du lycée national et l'éducation
nationale mais pour la gestion des
cantines la gestion de l'accueil
périscolaire parce que les parents ils
ont besoin d'être sécurisés de savoir
s'il va y avoir de l'école et qui ils
appellent ils appellent le maire le
président de département et qu'en même
temps la santé c'est quand même une
compétence régalienne et sur les
protocoles sanitaires il fallait bien
qu'il y ait des règles qui soient
édictées donc je trouve que c'est
l'exemple même d'un partenariat plutôt
intelligent ou les élus ils ont été
extrêmement responsable et très
innovateur
vous disais tout à l'heure quand ça vous
paraissait impensable ou improbables ou
aberrant que ce ne soit pas dans un
projet présidentiel on va justement
faire le point sur ce que proposent les
candidats sur le sujet en accueillant
marion vigreux marion qui a suivi ces
grands oraux pour nous
qu'est ce qu'il en ressort alors c'est
fabien roussel qui s'est exprimé en
premier et parmi les promesses du
candidat communiste et bien on a le fait
de réinstaller des services publics dans
chaque commune comme des trésorerie
municipale des permanences de la
sécurité sociale de la caf de la poste
mais aussi des guichets bancaires et des
distributeurs automatiques de billets
dans les villages pour fabien roussel
les communes sont asphyxiés et il
souhaite leur rendre sur 15 ans les 15
milliards d'euros prix sous le mandat
hollande rés libre et les territoires
casser les logiques des grandes
métropoles c'est aussi ce que souhaite à
marine le pen la candidate du
rassemblement national veut également
redonner du pouvoir aux maires comme le
droit d'urbanisme les mettre fin à l'
incompatibilité entre un mandat national
et un mandat de maire pour les communes
de moins de 30000 habitants et surtout
pas remis à ses mesures phares il ya la
suppression des ars les agences
régionales de santé qui n'ont pas
démontré leur efficacité et qui ont même
démontré je cite qu'elle était parfois
un obstacle à des solutions trouvées sur
le terrain anne hidalgo elle a commencé
par une forme de réquisitoire sur le
bilan au maquereau est effectivement la
candidate socialiste a déploré cette
politique centralisatrice qui a
largement entravé la créativité des
territoires parmi ces propositions
redonner donc de l'autonomie financière
et fiscale aux communes a déployé par
exemple des bornes électriques suspendre
les fermetures d'écoles dans les zones
rurales mais aussi mettre fin aux
déserts médicaux avec notamment cette
proposition que j'ouvre pas écouté et
une proposition qui consiste à utiliser
la réforme des études de médecine et
notamment de la quatrième année
d'internât pour que ce soit une année de
professionnalisation ou l'on puisse
envoyer les jeunes médecins en cours de
professionnalisation
dans les déserts médicaux et valérie
pécresse alors valérie pécresse
justement elle veut mettre en place le
plus puis son programme de
décentralisation du pays le temps des
libertés locales est venu at elle a
déclaré les régions doivent redevenir
des acteurs stratégiques mais aussi les
maires et elle propose également un choc
de simplification écoutez là un objectif
très simple diviser par deux le temps de
toutes les procédures administratives et
je veux donner la possibilité aux
collectivités territoriales d'adapter
les règlements nationaux j'y reviendrai
en fonction des réalités locales
plus de compétences plus d'autonomie
c'est aussi ce que propose
jadot pour le candidat europe écologie
aller vers soin de mettre en place une
grande politique d'aménagement du
territoire avec plus d'investissement
dans le ferroviaire une refonte du
modèle agricole mais aussi une refonte
de la politique des marchés publics je
cite le candidat ce n'est pas aux
préfets ou sous-préfets de dire quels
projets économiques au d'infrastructure
doit se développer enfin jean-luc
mélenchon a rappelé son attachement à la
commune c'est là que tout se joue la
naissance de la citoyenneté mais aussi
la préoccupation écologique aussi évoqué
à la santé lui qui a dénoncé les ars et
la politique de marchandisation des
hôpitaux et il propose notamment de
salariés les médecins pour résoudre ce
gros problème des déserts médicaux eh
bien merci mario et bravo pour ce résumé
des propositions de tous les côtés sous
ce nom parce qu'il y avait des absents
des absents avoir des absents est ce
qu'ils ont toujours tort forcément il y
en avait en tout cas qu'ils n'étaient
pas là c'est eric zemmour par exemple
qui pourtant multiplie les déclarations
à l'attention des territoires qu'il
estime aux oubliés on écoute
aux élites politiques ont négligé ces
territoires dans leur esprit vous étiez
fort encombrants dans la longue marche
vers la métropolisation vous n'étiez pas
assez intéressant pour la mondialisation
vous n'étiez pas aussi branché vous
n'étiez pas aussi sympathique que les
habitants des banlieues c'était à
châteaudun le 7 janvier dernier marcel
foucault il est centralisateur ou
décentralisateur gelé moore de ce que
vous avez pu entendre de ses discours
moi je dirais que comme d'autres
candidats il n'a probablement pas cette
culture culture politique de la
décentralisation et je crois qu'il ya
une certaine manière il est un peu à
l'unisson d'une partie du pays je me
suis un bilan quelque on avait mené en
juillet 2021 on l'interrogeait plus de
dix mille français moi j'étais frappé
d'observer que à la fois les français
ont une très mauvaise connaissance de ce
que ce qu'implique la décentralisation
cette culture politique je crois que le
terme de responsabilité politique a été
utilisée à plusieurs reprises pendant
cette journée
sénateurs d'arnaud l'évoqué massant et
c'est très important ce sujet éminemment
paul il a une dimension technique mais
nam en politique donc eric zemmour n'a
pas véritable cette culture de la
décentralisation en revanche je trouve
que lusage l'emploi du terme de
territoire depuis cinq ans est devenu
effectivement une sorte de neuf langues
chez beaucoup de responsables politiques
sans savoir exactement ce qui s'y passe
ce qu'ils sont les verrous aujourd'hui à
la fois terrain et terroirs et en
mélangeant tout oui sans avoir
d'ailleurs parfois on emploie le terme
d'aménagement du territoire on se
rappelle du décompte travaux de la datar
des années soixante dix années 80 en
pensant que l'aménagement va résoudre
tous les problèmes en fait quand on
parle de décentralisation pour moi c'est
éminemment politique pour deux raisons
très simples la première ça a été évoqué
effectivement par jean luc mélenchon
sent qu'il développe son propos mais
quand on retire des ressources la
capacité des collectivités territoriales
à prélever un impôt enfin la taxe
professionnelle la taxe d'habitation on
met à mal le modèle de citoyenneté le
consentement à l'impôt produit de la
citoyenneté et donc quand on retire au
niveau local cet élément je pense qu'on
détruit le modèle de citoyenneté et puis
une deuxième raison c'est la question
aujourd'hui dans cette moment où la
démocratie représentative est plutôt
abîmé retirer des éléments de
responsabilité on veut juger l'action
publique locale les maires ne demande
pas mieux que de pouvoir agir et d'être
évalués sur leurs réalisations et ne pas
être dans une confusion entre ceux qui
ne peuvent pas faire et sont évalués sur
cela et ce qu'ils font mais qui semble
être invisible pour les citoyens donc
une culture de décentralisation serre
mais tout cela à plat est allé j'allais
dire réparer ce modèle démocratique qui
demandent de la décentralisation et éric
kerrouche est ce que c'est une affaire
de gros sous la décentralisation parce
qu'au fond s'il n'y a pas de moyens
c'est difficile de transférer des
compétences ou donner de l'autonomie
c'est aussi une affaire c'est aussi une
affaire d'argent mais ce n'est pas
qu'une affaire d'argent la vraie
difficulté c'est que là la
décentralisation est inversement
connu par rapport à l'importance qu'elle
a dans la vie de dans la vie de tous les
jours c'est à dire que tous les services
dont on se sert localement sont très
importants pour la pardé la plupart des
français mais donc c'est pas forcément
les rattacher à tel ou tel niveau de
gouvernance et d'ailleurs c'est un
désintéresse ça les intéresse
relativement 2 maintenant une fois qui
as eu une fois passé ce niveau de mes
connaissances qu'on a on a deux
difficultés pour revenir directement à
celle que vous indiquez la première
c'est que si on a été très loin dans la
décentralisation comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure mathieu darnaud d'une certaine
façon l'état lui ne sait pas où il va
c'est à dire que l'état d'un plu
boussole territoriale alors que les
collectivités ont évolué et que en outre
pour mener des politiques publiques il
faut effectivement des moyens et on a
l'impression dans le temps que il y à un
appauvrissement des capacités d'action
des collectivités alors même et c'est le
paradoxe que les français notamment avec
la diffusion importante dans le
territoire par exemple suite aux cocos
vide alors que les français attendent de
plus en plus de services locaux donc on
va restreindre les capacités d'action
des collectivités
parce qu'elles ont moins de moyens alors
même que le niveau de service attendu
par les citoyens dans la plupart des
communes est de plus en plus et de plus
en plus important et je ne sais pas
comment on va résoudre ce paradoxe alors
on va y venir je vais parler d'un absent
il faut que je parle de l'autre c'est
parce qu'il ya un autre absent de marque
c'est emmanuel macron l'éthicien un
groupe à le président candidat n'était
pas candidat sur ce coup ah bah non il à
m est ce que vous savez pourquoi il est
pas venu et déjà première question non
non alors j'ai fait une toute petite
enquête rapide 1 n'est pas à pas
difficile cette enquête je vais vous
donner la réponse de l'elysée de ses
proches son équipe de campagne réponse
il ne fait pas d'audition voilà ça tient
en une phrase ok participer à un grand
oral l'audition donc par exemple devant
la cfdt il a envoyé richard ferrand donc
soit les organisateurs acceptent le
représentant des manuels macron sinon
tant pis c'est la réponse et quand je
continue en disant d'accord mais
pourquoi on me répond parce que son
agenda de président est contraint donc
toujours la même même message finalement
emmanuel macron président français prix
à 100 % quasiment par la guerre en
ukraine et en plus c'est un candidat qui
verrouille tout mathieu vous l'avez vue
est choisi dans quel média il va il
choisit que seront les conditions on l'a
vu hier soir sur tf1 et surtout son
propre média son propos il fait sa
websérie tous les vendredis soirs ils
postent des vidéos en veux tu en voilà
quasiment de façon quotidienne et ils
imposent toutes ces règles et tout le
monde pour l'instant les accepte hier
ils ne se sont pas croisés pas de photo
de groupe et donc il ne se rendra
personnellement à aucune audition parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est gagné d'avancé
que des coups à prendre attention
mathieu niel et par là vous allez trop
fort hein parce que la réponse ce qui
est fait et qui a été fabriqué ces on
est hyper mobilisés car rien n'est joué
il suffit juste d'écouter ce matin je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez entendu j'ai
bien dedans mendient qui est un proche
très proche des manuels macron est là la
question était est ce qu emmanuel macron
refusent de débattre par clip parce
qu'il sait que le match est plié écoutez
la réponse
candidat qui est candidat dès qu'il le
peut c'est à dire que dès que ses
obligations de président et c'est à dire
cette protection absolue des français ne
lui impose pas de rester prendre
président le candidat il s'est déjà
démultiplier la semaine dernière il va
continuer à se démultiplier cette
semaine pour aller à la rencontre des
français pour présenter son projet pour
débattre avec les journalistes et et
avec les français vous avez un candidat
dès qu'il le peut qui est mobilisée qui
veut présenter ce projet c'est quoi
l'avenir de notre pays c'est quoi ces
grands chantiers sur l'éducation la
santé c'est quoi ce large et seulement
rassuré dernière dernièrement comment
projetons nous tous ensemble de manière
unie notre pays dans les cinq prochaines
années m'ont dit
comme on dit familièrement et moulinet
c'est pas évident on s'en est encore on
a été très sympathique parce qu'on a
coupé sa grande hésitation du début
quand il prend la parole et on sent
vraiment qu'il est ennuyé un pour
répondre et ça ça va durer trois
semaines encore
rien n'oblige emmanuel macron légalement
à se rendre à un rendez vous ou à
débattre avec ses concurrents ni
constitutionnellement donc
simplement un risque d'image me
semble-t-il emmanuel macron pourrait
apparaître comme un homme qui manque de
courage et qui méprise ses adversaires
et le débat démocratique même si
plusieurs de ses prédécesseurs
censément d'excusés il faut juste
préciser pour faire une excuse parce que
lui stargate d'inventer un nouveau nom
et une nouvelle façon de faire la
politique françoise gatel vont vous le
soutenez maintenant vaincrons j'ai dit
que je soutenais emmanuel macron il a eu
tort de pamiers aujourd'hui je pense
alors moi je n'ai rien perdu ma liberté
j'ai expliqué pourquoi je soutenais
emmanuel macron ce n'est pas un soutien
individuel c'est un soutien leur
territoriale en l'occurrence que nous
sommes sept élus bretons ou en terre
bretagne et une culture centriste très
forte bon et que nous avons quelques
difficultés
non pas que la candidate valérie
pécresse qui est quelqu'un de très bien
moi je n'ai pas d'états d'âme un tu mets
sur des orientations qui sont prises ou
en bretagne c'est un peu compliqué donc
nous avons décidé en plus face à la
situation qui est extrêmement grave de
faire ce soutien donc moi j'assume et je
n'ai rien perdu de mes convictions
territoriale et je suis toujours très à
l'aise pour défendre ce qu'on a défendu
avec mathieu darnaud et je pense que
tous les candidats auraient dû finir
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ce été soulignée
par plusieurs d'entre eux y compris et
surtout ceux qui ont été écartés de
débats à tf1 qui ont dit qu'il saluait
l'initiative des associations d'élus
d'un vrai débat démocratique où tout le
monde pouvait être l'un est mort étaient
perdus oui et tout entendu dans les
mêmes conditions
alors emmanuel macron il a laissé
entendre que s'il était réélu il voulait
gouverner autrement un peu sur le modèle
des conventions citoyenne un peu sur la
méthode d'un grand débat permanent
écouter
quand je parle d'unité c'est que je veux
aussi que notre projet
qui est au fond une volonté qui se
construira autour de quelques axes forts
puisse
reposer sur une méthode un peu nouvelle
une méthode
associant davantage nos compatriotes et
les associons dans la durée et compris
le lendemain de l'élection en leur
donnant une place comme véritable acteur
mathieu darnaud est ce qu ils pas en
train de jouer les citoyens contre les
élus locaux et je crois que emmanuel
macron a eu largement l'occasion de
concerter de consulter je me souviens
des grands débats au moment de la crise
des gilet jaune là on réinvente un petit
peu ce qui a déjà eu lieu tout au long
de ce quinquennat je crois en réalité
singulièrement sur la question des
territoires et des collectivités que ça
restera l'angle mort de ses cinq années
de gouvernement où on a eu du mal depuis
le débat et le lancement de l' agence
nationale de cohésion des territoires au
sénat en 2010 est jusqu'à aujourd'hui à
imprimer à essayer justement d'incarner
cet esprit décentralisateur à se libérer
peut-être de ses chaînes sur le plan de
la déconcentration moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut revenir éric
kerrouche je disais tout à l'heure aux
actes
les mots c'est très bien ça traduit une
intention mais aujourd'hui nos élus et
croyez moi on ne rend compte sur le
terrain dans nos départements respectifs
ils veulent des actes ils veulent à la
fois un état qui est à leurs côtés plus
agilité plus de réactivité et il y a
quand même une donnée nouvelle c'est
celle de la différenciation
territoriales parce que je crois qu'on
ne peut plus attendre tout de la loi
aujourd'hui et que nous sommes dans un
temps où
les problématiques qui se posent dans
mon département de l'ardèche territoires
de montagne ne sont pas les mêmes que
les problématiques de l'ille-et-vilaine
ou des landes cheriki rouge donc je
crois que la loi est la même pour tous
mais pourquoi j'appelais de mes voeux
cet état territorial qui soit renforcée
parce que je me souviens j'avais un
enseignant qui le disait qu'on ne voyait
bien qu'avec ses pieds et cet état
territorial c'est préfet c'est sous
préfet ce sont eux qui doivent permettre
d'assouplir la loi la norme quand on met
face problématique très particulière par
exemple de construction sur les zones de
montagne que je représente au sénat
cette montagne ardéchoise parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
construire un mètre carré avec la
superposition d'une loi littoral d'une
loi montagne aujourd'hui les élus son
père lui ne comprennent plus donc cette
différenciation elle doit permettre
d'assouplir et de régler des sujets qui
finalement s'enkystent au fil du temps
donc des faits des actes est peut-être
moins de paroles ou de volonté de
réinventer une concertation parcelles
faut que je sais gré main
un petit point sur cette proposition des
mains le maquereau est ce que démocratie
citoyenne et démocratie locale plutôt la
démocratie des élus locaux ses
concurrents ou c'est complémentaire pour
vous pour renouveler un peu la vie
démocratique dans le pays disons que
s'il fait les à partir des propos d'
emmanuel macron prendre l'exemple de
l'expérimentation la convention
citoyenne pour le tournis dire
l'engagement d' emmanuel macron sur un
prochain quinquennat sera à l'image de
ce qui est advenu en termes législatifs
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le cas je serais très
inquiet pour ceux qui
seraient tentés deux fois à cette
formule d'accord alors on sait bien que
les premiers instants 10h que ceux qui y
croient ça a bien marché la démocratie
participative moi je pense qu'il y a il
ya un vrai sujet autour de cette idée
qui consiste à dire qu'on a trouvé la
pierre philosophale à tous les problèmes
démocratiques il s'agit de mettre une
couche de démocratie participative une
autre couche de démocratie consultative
et puis une autre couche de démocratie
délibérative et comme ça la démocratie
représentative vivra bien je pense qu'on
ne peut pas substitué à la démocratie
représentative c'est faux rebonds elles
peuvent être complémentaires c'est vrai
qu'il ya un sujet on arrive peut-être à
la fin d'un cycle de la démocratie
électorale c'est à dire le rendez vous
tous les cinq ans six ans où on convoque
les citoyens et entre ces deux moments
il ne se passe plus rien mais je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de de penser que ces
formes de démocratie complémentaire
serait la solution à tous les problèmes
et d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu pendant les
grands débats les réunions d'initiatives
locales je je je voyage avec mes
étudiants on observait ccsn et
finalement le profil des participants
était absolument pas à l'image de la
société française du corps social et
puis deuxièmement quand ces réunions se
tiennent prendre la parole en public
c'est pas la faire de tous ce n'est pas
simple et c'est pas simplement prendre
la parole pour sûr manifester comme une
insatisfaction il s'agit là montée de
contre argumenter de réviser ses propres
croyances sur des sujets s'est réservé
une fois des professionnels de la prise
de parole est longue plus tôt deminor en
plus je
sais ça ne permettent pas de retisser
réparer ce lien abîmée aujourd'hui les
masques ça peut permettre aussi
peut-être de résoudre la grosse
problématique à laquelle sont confrontés
les mères c'est la défiance politique
parce que moi je veux bien que les
maires à chaque fois se retourne vers
l'état vers le président envers
l'exécutif en disant mais enfin c'est
votre faute on n'est pas respectée sauf
qu'ils ont un problème sur le terrain
avec leurs administrés il y à la
violence il y a les invectives il y as
parfois les incivilités les agressions
donc c'était un problème ça pour le coup
très concrets de terrain qui n'est pas
due uniquement à l'exécutif et à l'état
centralisateur un choc françoise gatel
voulait répond pige après j'en passe la
part d'américains au chômage les étapes
à venir de là des centrales parce que on
a beaucoup parlé de l'abstention et de
du désintérêt profond d'eux pour de nous
consulter d'abord parce que je pense
qu'on en manque de résultats c'est à
dire c'est l'action publique n est pas
efficace et ainsi les citoyens ils
trouvent pas l'école il trouve pas le
médecin il trouve que ça ne sert à rien
d'aller d'aller voter puisque les gens
qu'il pourrait désigner pour faire les
choses ne le font pas ensuite sur la
démocratie participative
je partage l on a une impression de
trouver effectivement enfin moi je dis
soit le graal soit la pierre
philosophale sauf que ce qu'il faut
entendre c'est que aujourd'hui il est
nécessaire de faire ce qu'on appelle des
diagnostics partagés que nos concitoyens
quand vous êtes mère et que vous allez
construire un immeuble ce qu'aujourd'hui
on vous dit vous faites de la rénovation
urbaine vous densifie vous faites un
immeuble vous ne pouvez plus décider
tout seul avec votre conseiller c'est
pas faut aller expliquer aux gens faut
les faire venir fous qu'ils arpentent la
ville de façon à ce que le citoyen qui à
des années lumières des problématiques
ils comprennent les différentes
questions qui se posent ce qui fait qu'à
un moment la décision sulte hâtive dans
paris match où on explique aux gens
c'est la pédagogie mais à un moment
c'est la démocratie représentative qui
prend la décision elle est mieux
acceptée que si vous avez un peu
expliqué le contexte c'est comme
l'éducation des enfants avec les
citoyens éric kerrouche vrai convient la
décentralisation parce que mathieu
darnaud on a déjà un peu dessiné les
contours plus de différenciation dit-il
lui plus de droit à la différence au
fond en fonction des territoires ou des
collectivités locales pour vous
qu'est-ce qui quels sont les points
quels sont les leviers qu'il faut faire
avancer pour pauvres pour la
décentralisation
mais d'abord je crois que pour reprendre
justement les propos de mathieu darnaud
il faut sortir de la vision dans
laquelle l'égalité de traitement et le
fait de traiter tout le monde de la même
façon et la solution c'est exactement la
verse 1 seulement c'était la
différenciation qui est la garantie de
l'égalité entre les territoires parce
que ne pas prendre en compte des
disparités qui sont extrêmement marqué
c'est en fait nuire à tel ou tel
territoire donc il ya cet aspect
effectivement de prise en compte de la
réalité après sur la question il ya
d'autres questions dans la démocratie
dont excusez moi c'est m6 révélateur
dans la décentralisation et c'est
justement la question de la de la
démocratie parce que la décentralisation
est devenu quelque chose d extrêmement
technique il ya vraiment quelque chose à
voir de très simple vous regardez les le
compte rendu d'un conseil municipal au
début du 20e siècle et vous regardez le
compte rendu d'un du même conseil
municipal maintenant la technicité et
elle est incroyable elle rompt les
choses complètement l art on les change
complètement les morisques des élus qui
sont des experts
ou des professionnels de la profession a
séjourné on a on a des élus en tout cas
qui se tait cnis 6 parce que ils doivent
s'adapter aussi au monde dans lequel ils
vivent mais et après que les élus c'est
la société c'est la société en général
et donc la question de la démocratie
c'est simplement le fait que en france
la démocratie locale n'a pas été de pair
avec la décentralisation c'est à dire
que on a privilégié les structures mais
pour autant on a une démocratie qui est
très forte en france démocratie de ce
que j'appelle dans le livre avec vincent
ou même une démocratie procédurale c'est
à dire que on fait plus attention à
mettre en place des procédures de
démocratie qu'à faire en sorte que celle
ci contribue vraiment à la
démocratisation du du déblocage et le
coupé eric et au choix s'il reste une
minute mais vraiment une minute mais
merci beaucoup de
de ses lumières mathieu darnaud c'est un
processus irréversible pour vous la
décentralisation oui parce que nos
concitoyens appellent de leurs voeux
plus de proximité tout simplement et je
crois que c'est aussi le sens de
l'histoire pour ces raisons convient
d'évoquer la différenciation et pardon
de le dire on était en droit d'attendre
sur ce quinquennat un peu plus jédir
d'actes notamment vis-à-vis de cette
décentralisation et on nous l'avait
annoncé or aujourd'hui par bon de
prendre cette image mais on a eu deux
entrées avec l'engagement et proximité
la loi 3ds là où on attendait le plat de
résistance avec un grand texte qui
portait un souffle décentralisateur pas
un big bang c'est à dire qu'il fallait
pas réécrire toutes les règles du jeu
mais plus de décentralisation en un mot
plus de confiance dans les élus locaux
de la république marcel foucault c'est
une préoccupation des français lors du
vote ah oui fondamentales et la question
de la proximité aux lois c'est ça qui
nourrit le lien de confiance donc cassé
sous linux imiter c'est finalement
construire un avenir extrêmement
préoccupant sur la question de la
démocratie locale et la démocratie
locale on est un tournant parce que on
voyait bien que les maires dans les
années 70-80 n'avait pas ce lien de
confiance avec les français les français
faisait confiance à leurs députés
c'était la figure emblématique je révise
à 100g et donc effectivement c'est le
moment d'engager des réformes sur le
terrain la décentralisation et bien on
voit bien que ce n'est pas un sujet
seulement techniques administratifs mais
bien politique au sens de la vie de la
cité merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé merci martial foucault merci
françoise gatel mathieu darnaud merci
eric kerrouche laetitia à très bientôt
merci à tous